previously on TV Sims okay I get that
everyone is close on the show and we're
tuning in to watch the friends friend
but they're always be together not just
a few of them all of them even for a
silly midweek Chinese takeout dinner
Christ these are affluent New Yorkers in
their 30s and this is all they do I may
have watched this series too much
recently sorry but it still sit oh hey
you guys look ugly naked guys putting
stuff in boxes
fun fact naked guy putting stuff in
boxes is also the description for 93% of
all pornography ever produced why'd they
go to the slo-mo shots of the fountain
dancing for this season's intro was it
not already dramatic enough to just show
these [ __ ] jumping around and public
property nudists or not I'm highly
suspicious of anyone who needs a box
this large for underwear this box is a
cover-up for something horrible like a
lifetime supply of toenail clippings or
a month worth of receipts from CVS also
why would anyone be allowed in this
apartment without supervision by the
current tenant Janica getting caught
here is the most plot convenient
convenience to ever plot its convenience
that these two would do this in this
very room in front of these windows with
the shades open when they know that Ross
is thinking about renting the apartment
that's getting their line of sight it's
so asinine it may actually be assitant
okay fine the character of Ross leaves a
lot to be desired but the hell if David
Cooper isn't bringing it here I'm no art
expert but for the love of Freud is this
woman juggling her own disembodied boobs
because that seems like a sin to me
actually we saw them doing it up against
Phoebe and Rachel are acting
surprisingly casual about the Chandler
Monica hookup I think it's great they
must have done some serious therapy work
on the walk from the apartment because
moments ago they wanted to claw their
eyes out or we could not tell them we
know and have a little fun of our own
you know according to the parameters of
this show this is earth-shattering news
these mothers are insanely close and the
fact that two of them have been
surreptitiously dating would be a
massive development to these characters
but it's the show interested in
exploring the impact this has on the
group dynamic in this episode watch
learn and don't eat my cookie wait why
is Phoebe repeating exactly what my
college girlfriend told me every night
but also your cookie has been sitting
here since you bought it in five minutes
later you haven't even taken a bite none
yes I'm that guy the one that will ask
you if you're going to eat your
delicious food if you haven't touched it
for a while well you may think that's a
sin on me
listen on you for having a healthy
relationship with your food instead of
just gobbling it down quickly like the
rest of us hyenas but what about the
cookie jake hasn't learned the not so
subtle art of reading body language if
someone wants to talk to you they turn
their body toward you
unlike Louise who would rather throw her
neck out with a hundred and thirty
degree turn how did you get to these
thank you
my grandfather was Swedish and my
grandmother was actually a tiny little
bunny poor bunny
she touched my bicep for crying out loud
this bicep no actually what's the other
one I have quarters I mean I know
Phoebe's been planning this but she has
been lugging that bag of quarters around
with her just waiting and hoping modelur
would use a laundry excuse has anyone
ever figured out where ugly naked guy
lives these file aren't looking in the
same direction are there multiple ugly
naked guys your work makes me sad listen
to mrs. YouTube's comment section what
the are these mushroom key spices or
something can't believe he would do that
too much damn it this episode is some of
the best situation comedy to every
situation I'm gonna take off another sin
but now I feel like I'm going to have to
throw in a bonus round just so it looks
like I'm still doing my job a note of
caution even in your own home your
nudity could get you in trouble with the
law
technically answering the door nude is a
violation of most public decency
statutes but this is Morrison for the
show's obvious body shaming implied by
the build of ugly naked guy and that
he's constantly sipping on a big gulp oh
yeah they're totally gonna back down oh
yeah god damn it this show will never
acknowledge that the conversations in
this apartment are easily overheard by
the people sitting six feet away and my
team always wins I'll bet you your
apartment that this is demonstrably not
true and Chandler would never let her
get away with saying this if the penguin
is a secret I got secrets of my own you
know
you don't know about hugs easy my
bedtime penguin pound boobies you guys
done yet I want to sit in my chair but
Chandler said Joey's not gonna be here
tonight so why would Joey be expecting
to return to his apartment at all till
she cracks
is anyone still buying this at this
point isn't everyone so obviously
pretending that it just wouldn't be fun
anymore I can't have sex with you why
not because I love with Monica I love
her okay yeah the proclamation of love
is sweet no but you also know how much
Monica hates to lose so really the most
loving thing you could do would be to
bang Phoebe like you're Neil beer and
she's the number four rack Tom you know
for Monica and may I say your breasts
are still sharp this is a bra not a
breast
even with Ross now finding out this
episode title is completely fake news
considering Joey and Rachel already knew
what was going on so not everybody found
out in this episode I'm just saying this
entire episode is a lie and all your
good feelings are worthless you're
welcome
the big thing
[Music]
they March you in naked of the day you
were born
and then I would use you know the
strongest tool at my disposal my passion
for biology how did you get to be so
cute my grandfather was Swedish
and my grandmother was actually Jon Bon
Jovi yeah yeah they don't know that we
know that they know truly you have a
dizzying intellect like if I wanted
something from Joey I would strike up a
conversation about sandwiches that's
what I was gonna say I want to take off
all my clothes and have you rub lotion
on me it rubs the lotion on its skin or
else it gets the hose again